we're told della has over 500 songs on
her mobile phone and she wants to
estimate what proportion of the songs
are by a female artist she takes a
simple random sample that's what srs
stands for of 50 songs on her phone and
finds that 20 of the song sampled are by
a female artist
based on this sample which of the
following is a 99
confidence interval for the proportion
of songs on her phone that are by a
female artist so like always pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
on your own
della has a library of 500 songs right
over here and she's trying to figure out
the proportion that are sung by a female
artist she doesn't have the time to go
through all 500 songs to figure out the
true population proportion p so instead
she takes a sample of 50 songs and is
equal to 50. and from that she
calculates a sample proportion which you
could denote with p hat and she finds
that 20 out of the 50
are sung by a female 20 out of the 50
which is the same thing is 0.4 and then
she wants to construct a 99 percent
confidence interval
so before we even go about constructing
the confidence interval you want to
check to make sure that we're making
some valid assumptions we're using a
valid technique so before we actually
calculate the confidence interval let's
just make sure that our sampling
distribution is not distorted in some
way and so that we can with confidence
make a confidence interval
so the first condition is to make sure
that your sample is truly random
and they tell us that it's a simple
random sample so we'll take their word
for it
the next condition is to
assume
that your sampling distribution of the
sample proportions is approximately
normal and there you want to be
confident or you want to see that in
your sample you have at least 10
successes and at least 10 failures
well here we have 20 successes which
means well 50 minus 20 we have 30
failures so both of those are more than
10 and so meets that condition
and then the last condition is sometimes
it'll called the independence test or
the independence rule
or the 10 percent rule
if you're doing this sample with
replacement so if she were to look at
one song test whether it's a female or
not and then put it back in her pile and
then look at another song then each of
those observations would truly be
independent but we don't know that in
fact we'll assume that she didn't do it
with replacement and so if you don't do
it the replacement you can assume rough
independence for each observation of a
song if this is no more than 10
of the population and so it looks like
it is exactly 10 of the population so
della just squeezes through on our
independence test right over there
so that out of the way let's just think
about what the confidence interval is
going to be
well it's going to be
her sample proportion
plus or minus there's going to be some
critical value and this critical value
is going to be dictated by our
confidence level we want to have and
then that critical value times the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of the sample proportions
which we don't know and so instead of
having that we use the standard error of
the sample proportion and in this case
it would be p hat times 1 minus p hat
all of that over
n our sample size all of that over 50.
so what's this going to be we're going
to get p hat our sample proportion here
is 0.4
plus or minus i'll save the z star here
our critical value
for a little bit we're going to use a z
table for that and so we're going to
have 0.4 right over there 1 minus 0.4 is
times 0.6
all of that over 50. so we can already
look at some choices that look
interesting here this choice and this
choice both look interesting and the
main thing we have to reason through is
which one has a correct critical value
do we want to go 1.96 standard errors
above and below our sample proportion or
do we want to go
2.576 standard errors above and below
our sample proportion and the key is the
99
confidence level
now if we have a 99 confidence level one
way to think about it is
so let me just do my best shot at
drawing
a normal distribution here
and so if you want a 99 confidence level
that means you want to contain the 99
the middle 99
under the curve right over here that
area and so if this is 99
then this right over here is going to be
0.5 percent and this right over here is
0.5 percent
we want the z value that's going to
leave 0.5 percent above it and so that's
actually going to be
99.5 percent is what we want to look up
on the table and that's because many z
tables including the one that you might
see on something like an ap stats exam
they will have the area up to and
including
up to and including a certain value
and so they're not going to leave this
free right over here so let's just look
up 99.5 on our z table all right so
let me move this down so you can see it
all right that's our z table
let's see we're at
99. okay it's going to be right
in this area
right over here and so that is 2.5
looks like
2.57
or 2.5
2.58 around that
and so this right over here is about
2.57 it's between 2.57 and 2.58 which
gives us enough and for information to
answer this question it's definitely not
going to be this one right over here we
have 2.576
which is indeed between 2.57 and 2.58 so
let's remind ourselves we've been able
to construct our confidence interval
right over here
and but what does that actually mean
that means that if we were to repeatedly
take samples of size 50
and repeatedly use this technique to
construct confidence intervals that
roughly 99
of those intervals constructed this way
are going to contain our true population
parameter